it was a tumultuous day in the history
of brexit but more turmoil is likely to
follow on Thursday several members of
parliament resigned only hours after
Prime Minister Theresa May announced
that her cabinet had agreed to the terms
of the deal the first and biggest blow
was Dominic Raab quitting after only
four months as brexit Minister and he's
not the only one thinking this way
resistance is coming from within May's
own party reducing the chances of the
agreement being voted through Parliament
it's 84 now and it's going up by the L
will vote against it it is therefore
mathematically impossible to get this
deal through the house of politics and
if that wasn't enough May might be
facing yet another challenge Jacob Riis
MOG a vocal hard-line brexit ear
submitted a letter of no confidence
against the Prime Minister but what we
need is a leader who will say to the
European Union it is impossible to
divide up the United Kingdom it is
impossible to agree to a situation where
we have a perpetual customs union this
is not brexit this is a failure of
government policy it needs to be
rejected this is nothing to do with
personal ambition May responded to the
chaos with another press conference
demonstrating determination and
dismissing calls to step down if we do
not move forward with that agreement
nobody can know for sure the
consequences that will follow it would
be to take a path of deep and grave
uncertainty when the British people just
want us to get on with it this is a deal
which does deliver that which is in the
national interest and am I going to see
this through
yes for me the clock is ticking next
week she'll have to face EU leaders and
without parliamentary approval of the
BRICS a deal her days as Prime Minister
could be numbered all right she says
she's going to see it through but I'll
talk about that I'm joined now by
sunshine hiya
Kareem he is a member of Prime Minister
Teresa Mae's Conservative Party and he
represents northwest England in the
European Parliament he joins us tonight
from his constituents
see in birdly mr. Caribe it's it's good
to have you back on the day I wanted to
take a look at one of your tweets from
today you wrote and it seems the entire
Conservatives brexit movement are
resigning in mass and in a coordinated
manner abandoning their breaks it as it
breeds its last maybe we can now get
back to being a centrist party governing
in the national interest do you tonight
have any hope of of that happening well
good evening it's good to be back on to
your program and have this opportunity
to send a very clear message to your
viewers about where we actually are at
this moment in time the tweet that you
refer to makes it absolutely clear that
the only people today that have resigned
from government in the United Kingdom
were people who were committed briggsie
tears but not just committed briggsie
tears they are committed to a certain
type of brexit which is by and large
people who were committed to a no deal
exit from the European Union now that is
not something which delivers the
referendum result that the people of the
United Kingdom voted for in the
referendum and by removing themselves
from government there now give us the
opportunity to carry out a centrist and
center-right reform program for the
United Kingdom and indeed it leaves a
prime minister now free of the shackles
that these people had placed around her
to try and get her deal through the
House of Commons I don't say that
lightly I know that that is a tremendous
challenge that she sees ahead of her and
as I do the arithmetic the the numbers
don't currently stack up and you know
you strike me as being um a an optimist
as well the the main break sit here
still in government tonight at least for
now is the Prime Minister herself and we
know that she was not a die-hard
leave you know before she became Prime
Minister can she deliver the brexit that
she's promising the break said that you
and other conservatives would like to
see well actually
Teresa may campaigned for remain she
voted remain but she accepts the result
that was delivered and has said that she
will do her very best to reach the best
possible deal in the circumstances now
bearing in mind if you are leaving the
European Union it is an unrealistic
expectation that you will have greater
rights or the very same relationship and
rights as what you have whilst you are a
member of the European Union the
unfortunate thing is those who are
making unrealistic demands today
actually really expect to have a much
better deal than what they had as
members now that is an unrealistic
expectation that cannot be delivered
when one examines what Teresa May has
actually negotiated well in the
circumstances I cannot think of what
more could have been done by her or the
European Union to deliver a situation
that provides the best protections for
European citizens and the best basis
upon which our economy both in the
United Kingdom and in the European Union
member states can carry on in the least
friction effected way possible so this
is about as good as it gets and if
that's not good enough for these people
then they really have to be finally now
this is their last opportunity to be
honest with the people of the United
them and say to them that actually our
ideology dictates that we must destroy
parts of your lives and parts of the
economy in order to achieve our ideology
let me get you to take a listen to what
Jacob Riis Marx said earlier today this
threat about coming out against Teresa
may take a listen
the Conservative Party referendum on
which almost all conservative MPs stood
said specifically that we would leave
the customs union it did not have any
small print saying Oh unless we decide
to have a backstop that is a permanent
customs union that is harder to leave
than leaving the European Union under
article 50 now he's not alone in his
opinion and when I hear him and when I
hear you speaking it sounds like the
maybe the Conservative Party itself is
headed for a split and perhaps Teresa
may's days as Prime Minister are
numbered what do you say to those two
prospects well look I'm not somebody
that in any way tries to mask the
political realities that in staring
everybody in the face there is today a
fundamental split in the Conservative
Party there has actually been a real
challenge facing those of us that want
to be a centrist right political
movement and there has been a real
battle taking place for the heart and
soul of the Conservative Party and what
you are seeing today is actually that
now being fought out at the very last
stages through this brexit process and
what Jacob Riis MOG has actually set out
there puts in place a very clear
contrast between the battle that is
taking place between the two different
viewpoints one based upon ideology one
based upon pragmatism but what he argues
for and what the people of the United
Kingdom are now aware of is that
actually he is putting the unity of the
United Kingdom at risk when he puts
forward his arguments now during the EU
referendum campaign when we made these
very same arguments they dismissed it as
project fear now today they have been
absolutely unclothed in front of the
British people people like JP Jacob Riis
MOG now have nowhere left to hide and
simply dismiss his concerns is not now
going to
because these have become practical
realities that must be faced let me get
you to listen to what the European
Council President Donald Tusk what he
said today the u.s. prepared for a final
deal with the United Kingdom in November
we also prepared for a No Deal scenario
I mean is there any realistic chance of
that it means there is an area where
Britain does not leave the European
Union well there are basically three
things that can happen on a technical
basis and two on a practical basis one
is that there is a Briggs it without a
deal one is that there is a brexit with
a deal and then there is the third
option which is that there is no brexit
at all now I do not believe for a second
that there can be contemplated it brings
it without a deal the disruptions and
the consequences are just far too severe
for any British prime minister to
countenance and certainly our closest
trading partners in the European Union
will do everything to avoid that as well
so I really do not see the circumstance
arising where as a practical reality the
theoretical basis of delivery of brexit
on an ordeal basis comes to fruition I
don't see that that leaves two options
one is exiting with a deal now that
requires for the House of Commons to
vote and unanimously approve the
acceptance of the deal that Prime
Minister May has brought back now
currently the arithmetic is far too
challenging and it doesn't get through
that's quite clear whether that can
change over time we'll have to see what
the next few weeks brings and the very
last and final issue is one of no brexit
at all now there are several avenues
that lead to no breaks it at all but of
course when there having been a huge
public exercise through the ref
random they would need to be a further
Democratic exercise carried out that
delivers a result which allows for a
reversal of the article 50 notification
and the cancellation of brexit now that
could take one of two forms either a
general election or my third choice is
actually a people's vote mr. Kerem
virtually we're running out of time Matt
I'd love to talk with you longer but we
unfortunately yeah we're running out of
time and I guess we'll have to see what
happens in the next couple of days and
maybe we can come back to you to you
know to see if your predictions do come
true the Sonia Kareem from prime
minister Theresa mains Conservative
Party joining us tonight to talk about
the predicament that the Prime Minister
is in tonight mr. Karim thank you